[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]
FRANZISKA HINKELMANN: So we
are really excited that you
were able to join us this
morning because we are going
to tell you some very
cool things that you
can do with Node.js and Sheets.
My name is Franziska
Hinkelmann, I'm
an engineer at
Google in New York,
and I'm a Node Core
contributor, and I'm also
an elected member of the Node.js
Technical Steering Committee.
My co-presenter is Anu.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Hello, everyone.
My name is Anu Srivastava.
I have been an engineer at
Google for over five years,
mainly in Cloud.
Now I focus on G Suite, and I
own the developer experience
for the G Suite editor;
that's Doc, Sheets and Slides.
FRANZISKA HINKELMANN: So let's
get started with Work Less
and Do More, Sheets
for Node Developers.
When you work with a sheet,
your typical workflow
is that you first
collect the data.
Then you might have to
do some basic data prep,
like cleaning up time zones
or maybe translate user info
that you have in the sheet.
Once you've cleaned
up your data,
you can now analyze
it, which often
goes hand-in-hand
with visualizing it.
Why are we talking
to you about Sheets?
Well, Sheets has
this great advantage
that you can collaborate with
anybody, not just developers.
Sheets basically have
this universal language,
where anybody can edit data,
enter data, read the data,
sort it, filter it,
play around with it,
and then draw their own
conclusions from a Sheet.
Not only can anybody
work with a Sheet,
it's also really easy in
Sheets to visualize your data
in a chart.
You can create all kinds
of charts, of course--
bar charts, column charts,
pie charts, you name it.
Of course, as engineers,
we could be writing code
using a library like D3.js
that creates charts for us,
but that's a lot more work.
And when I need to
iterate quickly,
Sheets allow me to focus
on the data, the trends,
and the correlations,
instead of on the code.
Because of this,
Sheets is a great tool
if you want to experiment
and just prototype something.
Probably not a production tool,
but great for prototyping.
If we're honest here, entering
and editing data into Sheet
is not always the most
enjoyable task, at least
if you don't do this
on a regular basis.
Luckily, we can eliminate
those manual parts,
and we're going to show you now
exactly how you can do that.
ANU SRIVASTAVA:
And we love Node.
I hear Franzie
talking all the time
about how much she loves Node,
how great it is, she really
loves teaching people
how to use Node,
and she loves her work
maintaining the Node Core.
Honestly, before I started
sitting next to Franzie,
I primarily coded
in Java and Go.
But after learning how Async 08
works, I have been converted.
So today, we're going to write
a Node application to work
with Sheets.
So we're going to
use the Node client
library on the NPM registry.
This has a full-fledged
API for working with Sheets
that we can use.
This is an aside--
Sheets is actually
just one of the G Suite
set of productivity tools.
You can call these
APIs for free.
You don't need an
enterprise account.
And there's a lot
of stuff in here
that maybe you use every
day, like Gmail, Drive Docs.
If you've been watching a
lot of the talks on Cloud,
you might have primarily
heard about GCP.
But Google Cloud is
both G Suite and GCP.
Most of these APIs are
generated the same way,
so they look and
feel pretty similar
when you're working with them.
You use the same account;
they're in the same family;
you enable the
APIs the same way.
So don't worry if you're
not a Node person.
We have client libraries,
SDKs, and many languages,
and it makes it easy to use
these APIs in a canonical way.
So I already
mentioned Java and Go,
but we have everything from
PHP to Ruby, even .net.
We'll be focusing on Node today.
So let's get started with
a quick "Hello World!"
So we're going to be
writing a script that
could be running locally on,
maybe, my laptop, my machine.
And it's talking to
the Sheets service
to make modifications
on my behalf.
So we start by
requiring the package.
Then we initialize
the Sheets client.
And then, right above
there, we see a long string.
That is the authorization scope.
So the scope is
the level of access
we want to grant to our script.
I don't know about
you, but when I'm
installing a new application,
I get really nervous when
it starts to ask for a lot of
permission to my user data,
if it wants full
access to my Drive,
it wants to read my emails,
it wants my location history,
shoe size, mother's maiden
name, social security number.
It is really bad practice to
ask for more access to user data
than you actually need.
And we'll be talking about best
practices for Auth later today.
And then also, don't
worry about trying
to memorize the code that
we're going to show you.
All of it is on GitHub, and
then we will send out this link
after the talk.
So back to "Hello World!"
We make our call to
actually write the data,
then we need to tell the service
where to insert "Hello World!"
So, in Sheets, we specify cells
by what we call A1 notation.
So today, we're actually just
writing to the very first cell.
We're using modern syntax.
And, once we run that--
and if we go to the browser
and actually open the Sheet--
this is what it looks like.
We wrote to that
very first cell.
And if you remember from that
API call that we just showed,
you need to specify
the spreadsheet ID.
Well, that ID, conveniently,
is the same one
you find in the URL if you're
looking in the browser.
So if you're at the point that
you are using the Sheets API,
you're probably going to need
to write to more than just
one cell at a time.
And the best way to do
this is to actually group
your write requests
together when it's possible.
We have this concept
called the batch update--
the batch update method--
in many G Suite APIs,
and it's the best way
to make modifications in bulk.
So why should you group
your requests together
with batching?
There are two main reasons.
So the first is, every
time any application
makes a network call, there's
a little bit of overhead,
some latency for setting all
that up and receiving it.
When you group
them together, you
can actually reduce that total
latency for all of those calls.
The second is, these
APIs are free to use.
However, you are bound
by quota restrictions.
So when you group them
together into a single request,
you'll be using
dramatically less quota.
So each one of those
tasks that you see--
that's going to actually be
a different type of write,
and you can still
group them together.
So let's look at all the
different things you can do.
Think of batch update as
like a big fancy list,
or like a bucket for all
your different modifications.
It's like a really big
hammer for many of the tasks
that you can do in the UI.
So we already saw that
you can write data.
We'll be talking a lot
about adding charts today.
And you can do other
things, like even
add developer metadata.
So now that we have
a basic toolkit
for working with
the Sheets service,
let's actually try to
solve a real-world problem.
So I sit next to
Franzie, and I frequently
see her looking at the Insights
tab for the Node Core repo.
So this is a repo that
has the Node.js runtime.
She is very concerned with
the health of this repo.
The inside tab gives
you a lot of metrics
about the number of issues
and pull requests over time.
However, this tab only
gives you insights
into what's going
on within GitHub.
But if you've ever had
a long day at work,
you know that there are
many different things that
go into how productive we are.
You can't really
see things like, oh,
are people being blocked
by the Jenkins CI,
and that's reducing the
number of pull requests
they could be making?
You can't see if maybe
they're stuck in traffic.
That's why they
can't close issues.
There's a lot of
things happening.
What if just how well-fed
people are dramatically
affects their productivity?
Franzie wants to get
a holistic picture
into what helps people
be more productive.
So let's focus in on
one of those questions
that we're very curious
about but that's
kind of hard to define.
We're going to go a little
silly today, so bear with us.
We want to experiment
and see if we
can see if food satisfaction
yields better GitHub metrics.
So this is a hard problem, not
from a technical perspective,
but a real-world perspective.
We have our contributors at
their machines, we have GitHub,
and we have the food.
We want an application to tie it
all together so we can automate
gathering these
metrics, which is
why we're going to use
Sheets, so we can quickly
manipulate that data.
We're going to write
some code in Node
to monitor the Node repo.
So let's get started
by breaking this down.
FRANZISKA HINKELMANN:
So my theory
is that we work better
if we're well-fed.
But we want to see the metrics.
Let's look at the
data to prove this.
First thing we have to do is
collect the data as a new set.
We're going to get this
from the GitHub repository.
We are specifically interested
in how many pull requests are
merged, how many
issues are closed,
and overall, how many
open issues and pull
requests do we have?
So how do we get this data?
Well, GitHub has a
very nice REST API,
and if we use Octokit to GitHub
REST API client for JavaScript,
it's very easy to get this data.
And the API gives us
exactly the same data
that we would get
in the Insights tab.
So it's really just a
few very straightforward
API calls to get this
data programmatically.
And, once we have
the data from GitHub,
we will write it
to a spreadsheet.
So, just like in the
"Hello World!" example
where we wrote "Hello
World!", now we're
writing the numbers
that we got from GitHub.
Of course, I could have console
logged the results from GitHub,
copied that, and then manually
pasted it into a spreadsheet.
But that's manual.
I might be making mistakes.
I don't want to do it,
so I'm using an API call.
Now onto the food part.
We love metrics and
surveys, so we did a survey.
In this survey, we
figure out how happy
the contributors are with
their food on a daily basis.
Super scientific.
Every time you
use a Google form,
the results are automatically
written to a spreadsheet,
so here we just
configure the form
to use the same
spreadsheet that we also
used for our write calls
of the GitHub data.
All right.
Now that we have the data both
for GitHub and for food, now
we are interested in whether
there are any correlations.
If we are hungry, do
we close more issues
because we want to get
done and leave to get food?
Or if we had too much
food, are we much slower
and we don't merge
any pull requests?
Or if we're hungry, maybe we
just open issue after issue.
How can we see
these correlations?
Well, a quick way is with
a chart, so let's do that.
Here's the chart.
We'll look at the results later.
For now, we're just interested
in how we get this chart.
Of course, you can go to
the Sheet you've highlighted
and then click Add Chart.
But we don't want
to do this manually,
so we would use an API call.
Let's see what the code
for this looks like.
So if we want to
create a chart, we
have to create an
Add Chart request.
This Add Chart
request has a chart,
and we have to pass on the
specification for the chart.
Once we've built our
request, then we're
using our friend batchUpdate
to send this Add Chart request.
A few chart parameters I
want to point out here--
one thing you have to
specify is the type.
So we are creating a line chart.
Then you need the domain.
The domain is your x-axis.
So in our case, it's the date.
We want to see how are the
trends changing over time,
so we put the date
as the domain.
And then, probably the most
important part of a chart
is the series, the data series.
So, in our case, the numbers
we got from GitHub of how many
issues and pull requests.
So our architecture
overall looks like this.
We have two data sources.
We pull the data and we
write it to a spreadsheet,
and then the sheet
creates a chart for us.
And we're doing all
of this locally.
We're not opening
a sheet and running
anything inside the sheet.
All this Node code
runs on our machine.
We can control the Node
version that we're running,
and it's just interacting
with the REST API.
Anu is now going to take
this one step further.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Whoo-hoo.
Yeah.
So we're gathering the data,
and we're getting insights.
However, it's only running
locally on a machine,
so only one team member
has access to it.
We should really host
this as a service.
We are in the Cloud
track, after all.
So ideally, this would
be a fully-fledged app
with a client and a server.
But we actually know
that it's really not
just those two parts.
If you want to get all those
good principles that we have
in Cloud, like high
availability, fault tolerance,
we probably need to
add multiple servers.
When you have multiple
servers, you probably
need a load balancer to
distribute those requests.
Maybe you need a
cache somewhere.
There's a lot of
different pieces
that you need to set up
to have a real server.
Franzie and I only want
to focus on our code, not
the infrastructure.
So we decide to go
investigate other options.
This is how we land
on serverless in GCP.
So with serverless, you just
get to upload your code,
and then the Cloud
provider figures out
how to place and scale
it on your behalf.
We don't need to know, or
even really want to know,
anything about the machines
that our code is running on.
And you only have to pay for the
time that your code is running.
So this is really great, because
to do a fetch of all the data
and produce a chart, it doesn't
take more than a few minutes.
But if we were to
put this on a VM,
we'd probably be paying for that
to just sit there idly 24/7.
Then "Open" over
there just means
that you get to use the
tools and the frameworks
and the languages that
you're already familiar with.
Since we're working
with Node today,
we're going to be using
the Express framework.
If you're working
with Python, you'll
be using Flask, and all
of those good pairs.
So there's a few
different products
in the serverless family.
We decide to go with
Cloud Functions.
So Cloud Functions,
in a nutshell--
they are narrow, focused bits of
code that you upload to Google,
and then you trigger
them by events.
So we have background events
that they respond to--
some of your other
Cloud services,
you can think of them as
like glue for connecting
all these pieces.
Maybe you trigger an event
by uploading some files
to your GCS bucket.
Maybe you're listening to
incoming Pub/Sub messages.
We're actually going to be
working with HTTP functions
today.
Those are more common,
and they are triggered
by what you'd probably expect--
HTTP requests.
They're really good
for things where
you need to either
process data, like us,
or maybe you're calling
external services.
So, in the real world,
people use them for things
like, OK, I want to do
credit card payments,
so maybe I'm talking to Stripe.
Maybe I want to
send text messages,
so I'll be using Twilio.
Let's look at a quick "Hello
World!" for HTTP functions.
So I keep saying
the word "function."
Is that really what I mean?
Yes.
With two lines of code, you have
a fully operational back end.
After you deploy
this, you don't need
any additional configuration,
like a gateway.
With Google Cloud Functions,
you get a fully-provisioned end
point on a
fully-qualified domain.
And this handles the
SSL [INAUDIBLE] for you.
And we mentioned the framework.
So those requests and
response objects--
those are from the
Express framework.
So, now that we know a little
bit about Cloud functions,
we're going to keep
that code that we
had in our first version.
We're just going to wrap
it up in our local script,
and then deploy it so we
have a serverless back end
for our system.
This service will read our
data from our external sources,
and then produce a chart,
all while running in a data
center somewhere in the cloud.
So we upload the
code that we already
have together with
an exported function.
We'll call it githubChart.
And then that calls
our main logic.
So after all that
processing is done,
we send a 200 status code,
just like a "Hello World!"
And then here, we're
going to send back
the ID of the spreadsheet,
which has our chart.
So how do we deploy
this function?
That sounds like it
might be hard or scary.
It's actually really easy.
You can use the gcloud CLI.
The gcloud CLI is a
tool that you can use
to manage all your GCP tasks.
So with functions,
you just have to pass
in the name of your
exported function.
So that's why we see
githubChart again.
So it uploads your code.
It picks up your
package.json, not
the node modules themselves.
So this is really nice if you
have slow data connections.
It's just picking
up your source code,
and then it built it
in the cloud for you.
We also edit and
deploy the function
straight from the
Cloud console as well.
The Cloud console
is the web interface
where you manage
your Cloud services,
and then you turn on
APIs and look at all
your monitoring and
stuff like that.
So the code is in the
cloud, but it still
needs to be triggered
manually by a human.
We want to keep pulling
in this data regularly
and keep tracking our
productivity over time.
So instead of needing
a person to trigger
this function every day, we can
actually schedule the function
by using Cloud Scheduler.
In my opinion, Cloud
Scheduler is just
big, fancy cron in the cloud.
We set up this cron job in
the Cloud console as well.
You use the same syntax as
if you were using basic cron.
We have ours set to run
every morning at 9:00 AM.
And then, down at the
bottom, we specify
that HTTP URL we got back
from Cloud Functions.
So now we have a back end job to
do all of our data collection.
And Franzie's going to take
you through adding a client.
FRANZISKA HINKELMANN: So when
we trigger and HTTP end point,
our code is run on a function.
But for more functionality,
it would be nice
if we had a front end client
so we don't have to memorize
a bunch of HTTP end points.
So we add a client
that sends out emails
to the team with the new chart.
And since we're
dealing with emails,
we're going to use the
Gmail API for this task.
Let's look at our front
end code for this.
So just like in the
back end with Node.js,
we have client libraries
on the front end.
And then for Gmail, if
you want to send an email,
it's really straightforward,
Gmail.users.messages.send.
You have to include
your raw email here.
That's just Base64 encoded
off your content, which
could be plain text or HTML.
So now we have the
front end OR cron
job triggering the
Cloud function,
which pulls the new data
and creates a chart.
And when that is done,
then the front end
will send out an email
with this new chart
to everybody on the team.
Is that the whole story, though?
Just kidding.
We laughed that off.
Authorization-- you don't
want others to send out
emails on your behalf,
and you don't want anybody
to read and write
your spreadsheets.
So let's have a look at
how we do authorization
in our application.
In our front end, we have
an Authorize or Login button
that triggers the
Google Sign-in flow.
Google Sigin-in is a secure
authentication system
that allows users to log in
with their Google account
that they already have.
And then they can
authorize your app
to use Google services like
Gmail on behalf of them
in a secure manner.
Google uses the
OAuth 2.0 protocols.
So the way this works
is your application
asks for user consent, like
you just saw, and only then it
can access user data.
So the key point here is that
your application with OS 2
does never ask for the
user's credentials.
It only gets consent to
then access user data
on behalf of the user.
So, remember, OAuth 2.0, it's
consent instead of credentials.
Let's look at how the
protocol works in detail.
This authorization flow is
also called three-legged OAuth.
The entities are your JavaScript
front end, the Google Service,
and the end user
that's consenting.
So when you want to
access user data,
you first send a request
to the Google Auth server,
and then the end user has
to log in and consent.
If they did that
successfully, then you
get a token from
the Auth server,
and now you can use this
token for all your requests
to the Google APIs, like
Gmail, to send emails
on behalf of that end user.
Luckily, the client
libraries handle this for us,
so we don't have to worry
about the implementation
details of three-legged OAuth.
One thing that you
have to specify
when you initialize the
clients to Google API's client
is the scopes.
Anu already mentioned
them earlier for Sheets.
So now we're using
the Gmail.send scope.
So that means when you
request the Gmail.send scope,
when the user goes through
the Google assignment,
then it actually says,
do you allow this app
to send emails on your behalf?
And if users approve
that, the token
that we get back
from the Auth server
is only good for this scope.
If I take this token
now and I'm like,
oh, I'm going to
touch your Sheets,
then I get a 403, because that's
not what the user consented to.
Obviously, you always
want to keep the scope as
restrictive as possible.
There's lots of
different scopes.
Definitely have a
look at them if you're
working with the Google APIs.
I want to quickly point out
this one scope, drive.file.
This is really nice,
because instead
of granting access to all
your Sheets, for example,
you're only granting
permission to the app
to touch the Sheets that the
app itself created, or maybe
explicitly was given permission.
So this is a good
one, because users
don't have to worry
that your app can
read all their documents.
All right, so on the front
end, we have a login button,
and then this consent
screen pops up,
and the end user has to click
so that you can access--
that you can send emails
on behalf of the users.
How are we handling
Auth in our back end?
We decided that our back
end--so the part where the Cloud
Function talks to
the Google Sheet--
will not have any
end users involved.
Instead, we have that the sheet
belongs to the application.
So our back end is not accessing
a new Sheet or my Sheet.
It's accessing a Sheet
that actually belongs
to this application,
and we're doing
server-to-server
authorization here.
Heads up, though-- if you're
working with the G Suite API,
best practice is that you should
work with user credentials
and three-legged OAuth.
Usually, you don't
want the documents
to belong to the application.
So in the back end, we
have two-legged OAuth.
We have two entities.
We have the back end of the
application and the Google
servers.
There is no end
user involved here.
And server-to-server
authentication
uses JSON Web Tokens,
JWTs, to request a token
from the Google Auth server.
And then it can use that token
to access to Google APIs,
but this time on behalf
of the application,
not on behalf of somebody else.
Again, here, use the
client libraries.
They wrap this workflow
for you, so you
don't have to create and
sign your own JSON Web Token.
Comparing three-legged
and two-legged OAuth--
so three-legged OAuth is always
on behalf of an end user,
and it requires consent
from this end user.
And for G Suite APIs,
the best practice
is to use three-legged OAuth.
Two-legged OAuth,
on the other hand,
is server-to-server
authorization,
and the requests are made on
behalf of the application.
And the resources belong
to the application, not
your end users.
And under the hood, two-legged
OAuth is using JSON Web Tokens.
FRANZISKA HINKELMANN: Thank
you for that really detailed
comparison about the
different types of Auth.
So like Franzie
said, this is all
handled for you by
our client libraries
if you choose to use them.
If you look at the quick
starts in our documentation,
they actually show
you how to get set up
with this in just a few steps.
It's really important
to use OAuth,
because now you're
working with tokens,
not people's actual passwords.
We don't want people
storing them, especially
not in plain text.
So now that we have
all that set up,
what was the whole point of
writing this application?
It was to see if
we can get insights
into if food satisfaction
boosts our GitHub productivity.
So let's look at some of
those charts more closely.
We made a lot of charts
with our sample data
that we were running
through April.
We can see a bit
of a correlation.
So this chart has all
the different metrics
that we were tracking.
The left-hand side has
the scale of the number
of issues, open issues.
So that's in the hundreds.
But then on the
right-hand side, we
have the scale of the PRs
and our food satisfaction.
So if you remember that
survey, it was from 1 to 5.
Let's look at some more charts
that break this down a little
bit further.
So if we look at pull
requests specifically,
looks like we merge PRs
when we're better fed.
Again, these line charts
show trends a lot more
quickly than if
you're trying to look
at these numbers
in your console.
So especially this one--
I like this one,
because it shows
closed issues and merged PRs.
Those are like our
completed tasks.
So after we write
this code, we never
have to manually open Sheets
again to get our insights.
Now that we have this
data, we could easily
add data from more sources.
Say we could actually get
traffic, commute times--
more realistically, things
you probably already have,
maybe some other internal
systems that you're using,
application monitoring-- other
APIs so that you have around,
you know how to add
stuff into Sheets.
So in conclusion, good
food yields good code,
and now we have the
data to back it up,
if anybody wants the proof.
We're going to tack on one
last thing to our system.
So another workflow that
we see a lot is people
having to create reports
regularly of data
just like this, maybe for
their managers or team meetings
that you frequently have.
And I don't know too many
people who are really
jazzed about making
reports, so let's see
if we can do some automation.
So, yeah, these
reports-- you might
have to make them weekly,
monthly, quarterly, maybe
some salespeople who make
these types of reports
for their clients.
They could be in a [INAUDIBLE].
They could be in a Google Doc.
Maybe we just want to prove
our good food trend over time,
so we share this
info with people
all across the company
in a Doc that's
quick and easy to look at.
So maybe you specifically
don't have to do this,
but maybe you probably
know someone who does,
and you can make them really
happy by scripting this
as well.
So let's look at a
sample report and then
see how we can automate
this with the APIs
that we're already using.
If you've ever had to do
this sort of thing yourself,
maybe the first thing you do
is create a copy of an old one,
and then you start manually
updating that data.
This can be super tedious.
It can be really error-prone.
It's easy to miss pieces of
data that you need to update.
And then, well, what
if you use a template?
Templates are pretty
common, but you still
have to do some manual work.
So we're going to
completely automate this.
You can use the Drive API
to make a copy for you,
and then we'll use
Slides to actually merge
in all that data.
We'll look at some
of the pieces of data
that we've got to update.
For example, on
our first slide, we
have the report generated date.
So we're going to create
a Slides API client.
This syntax should
look really familiar.
And then that date that we
saw on that first slide--
we can actually make a
replaceAllText request
to update it with today's date.
And you guessed
it. replaceAllText
is a type of batch update.
And we can do this for
other text placeholders.
You can replace
any sort of text.
I just happen to use all
caps with curly brackets
so I know what our
placeholder is.
But maybe we had a slide
summarizing the total number
of pull requests and issues.
So now let's look at how to
add our charts that we made.
What's really nice
about these APIs
that they're tightly coupled
together the same way
that the products are.
So Slides has a method
called Create Sheets Chart,
and you can get the chart
by its chart ID, which
you can get via the Sheets API.
And then, if you write
a script with all
of these different
code snippets,
you can completely automate
generating a report
with no human intervention.
This could save you or your
co-workers hours and hours
of time.
So now that we've
added reporting,
let's take a step back
and look at the system
that we designed today.
We designed a basic
reporting system
using Node and our G
Suite and GCP APIs.
So our front end
triggers a Cloud function
that fetches data from external
sources and creates a chart.
Now, we have multiple ways
of sharing this information,
either via email or a report.
At its core, we're using
Sheets as a data manipulation
and collection tool.
So our experimental app
investigates if lunch
affects our productivity.
We know this probably
isn't exactly what
you or your company
needs right now.
You probably already have
dashboards and analytics.
But what we really wanted to do
was inspire you to be creative
and think of some
non-technical problems
and solve it with the tools that
you are probably already using
every day.
We really hope you have fun
coding on your next project
with Node.js.
Our completed code is on GitHub,
so feel free to tweet at us
and let us know what you think.
Thank you, everyone, for
tuning in on the livestream.
And for everyone
here today, we would
love to answer your
questions right outside.
We look forward to meeting
you, and have a great time
with the rest of IO.
FRANZISKA HINKELMANN: Thank you.